no I just got your boy Sean I just go  Danny  I had to don't sound too good after you  know people are sound if you can't get  to new he's gonna go after your family  people at his wife's family's house  wearing my rougher hell and know how  this works  the cops sent their own motivation  you've got to worry about stanca life so  what happens now I'm the best chance  you've got  drink coffee Artic yeah six cups a day  for the last thirty years so then a  little extra sugar it's gonna be a long  night  I'm here asking for my son's life Shawn  you know this just and I'm coming after  your boy with everything I've got  the one that's done and it will be done  then I'll let you die I do what I have  to do to protect my son